yawa come to this video playing against
c4 I'm playing at the b6 line the
English Defence let's see how this is
good is playing on the delay to define I
like those positions more than one y
term place without deform okay f3 f3
isn't a great move but what's the reason
what is the reason
yeah I can take take take everything
take on e4 with Queen h4 bird he's got
queen age 5 this is so this is a problem
takes takes Bishop takes be takes Bishop
before Bishop before Queen h4s grade but
I'd be sure before he's got Queen h5
check and Queenie five stuff like that
okay I'll play a developing move this is
some
also find I hope so let's go here I
intended 'if I've but if I've he's got d
594 Queen h5 this is sam this is bad hmm
okay maybe I'm d5 I need to go 97 so
that I've night g6 gem came must do that
Queen age 596 is ok ok this is not
exactly great for black am I think I
must play something else on f3 but I
don't know I don't know what exactly I
think you can even refute it but a 3 is
bad but i forgot why
really I thought this would just give me
a temple with Knight f6 next move
hmm yeah that's weird okay should I take
mmm and make sure it is doubled yeah
yeah come on and now d 6 l with bishop
see aid he can play 95 and 96 but I can
I can just take it and it's it's not a
big deal
yeah the problem is he goes 96 I play
Queenie 7 and take it hmm night a try
before him and wonder should i cancel
first or plane at age five minutes let's
play it let's play it instantly on Queen
f3 that's night fo and the night hags
and also d3 is hanging so this looks am
really comfortable
taking with the pawn maybe also was
pretty good yeah okay so take it on some
better move I mean this must be must be
excellent so castles and 96 to see 5 I
take first too much castle so let's do
it here and now 95 m and it's got this
this terrible bishop and I just got this
extra porn I just need to exchange now
to to get to a winning ending yeah so
not much fun just I can just just
exchange everything off and and win the
ending with this rag pawns and perfect
structure for black let's just quickly
though look at this I mean f3 is really
not a good move but I forgot forgot why
okay the computer doesn't give anything
special so maybe I'm wrong I really
thought I would be able to win material
or something or at least get a good
position I point is that this CM if you
look at this at first you might think
that this is great because Bishop takes
Queen takes and and you win but the
problem is that after this move why does
God oops this this check here and this
is the problem it covers the square and
so you cannot just play here you need to
play g6 and then is Queenie 5 look at
this oops no this one this is very
embarrassing you can try something like
this and and after this year you're down
yeah this is hanging this is hanging a
black just just lost I knew that this
isn't working but yeah well what I
played is probably in or riot but
nothing nothing great okay thanks for
watching